holy cow
[Laughter]
no no this is a real tweet I didn't
write this tweet I'm walking away
[Music]
hey what's up I'm James I'm Carlos I'm
Kendall I'm Logan and we are Big Time
Rush and we are reading buzzfeeds
there's tweets how is every member of
Big Time Rush still hot aged like wine
all of them wow we drink a lot of wine
so hey Botox part of it yeah yeah
exactly I like that tweet I'm a fan of
that tweet that is that's nice I feel
warm inside it is it's nice I think
moisturizer helps yeah I would say sleep
but we got like three hours last night
so we could still look good yeah that's
the thing though still look good there
you go Mr Logan Henderson you are
respectfully so fine thank you you're
welcome I tweeted oh is that you okay I
was thinking that that handles weird
that James Maslow that is you okay well
you were looking you were looking just
so Dapper love you buddy I had the
fattest crush on Kendall Schmidt I'm
such a hoe for a boy with thick brows
thank you for that because I put a lot
of work into these things into the brow
it's the caterpillar brow it's the
caterpillars and they honestly they
frame the face and he's got a lot of
thick facial features when I was younger
I actually went and got them shaped and
and I stopped doing that because it just
felt kind of out of place for me so you
just let him go now I want to be full
and thick if you think that's sick you
should see his back hair yeah
boy James Maslow is really sexy as
respectfully now that one was me you
know that one was me and you said
respectfully too which is nice Logan
Henderson Kendall Schmidt caused by the
Vega James Maslow they're all so so hot
and I won't accept anything different
well who knows in a few years I mean
maybe we'll be so so so so hot or not at
all age terrible no remember the botox
okay we're good whatever it takes
whatever it takes we're happy to set the
bar we're happy to set the bar whoever
found these tweets just good on you
totally yeah only short man that can
look at me is Carlos PenaVega okay
that's some short man love I like that
not saying I would let Logan Henderson
from Big Time Rush run me but I would
absolutely let Logan Henderson from Big
Time Rush ruin me oh my gosh please
don't say this one's foreign
specific kind of love well you know what
I'll ruin your life Carlos PenaVega or
hot Latina with a bigger ass than his
wifey sorry Alexa
[Laughter]
she's been doing a lot of squads babe
and leg lifts and all that kind of stuff
she's killing it right yeah like well
you guys both have she's a hot mama nice
booties well-rounded rear side I would
still let James from Big Time Rush hit
me with his car honestly gosh what is
going we got the Tesla maybe just I mean
she would never hear it self-driving I
don't know how to respond to that but I
think I think that's respectfully
respectively respectfully I will run you
over Big Time Rush music makes me wet
there I said it Dream Drop what
make sure you grab an umbrella okay
because it's going down I'll tell you
what you're gonna not be able to you you
can't get enough I was trying to I was
trying to I feel like we shouldn't
follow up on this one we should just let
this one right slide it wasn't a
moisture reference Logan Henderson is a
sex god why are you say it like that I
just kind of felt like it matched this
tweet okay Kendall Hugo Kendall from Big
Time Rush makes me feral you should
probably get that checked out hey wow
what a choice it happens I want Big Time
Rush to suck on my fat toes a lot of
footage
stuff I mean isn't there a thing called
like foot finder have you ever sucked on
toes I don't think that's a thing that
I've done okay I might have a couple
times a couple times all right Logan
Henderson really went from I'll have
your daughter home by eight to even your
wife call me Daddy
that's pretty funny actually Kendall
Kendall Schmidt is still Daddy's and
that's funny I'm not a daddy yet
it doesn't mean he's not trying dad of
the group in some ways somehow Big Time
Rush is the gift of daddies Carlos
PenaVega and James Maslow are my father
just add it to the bunch you already
have some wow you might as well just add
it on man Daddy Daddy yeah Daddy right
love it oh my gosh I just want a giant
orgy with Big Time Rush and guys I'm
sorry I'm not gonna participate in that
all right
the stage is what I who who is it that
makes you not want to do this is it me
I'm not gonna say who it is but you know
what I think we We Tour so much together
I don't want to cross the line it's
Kendall for me
um
this is like that movie original sin
this one yeah okay I would like for
those of you who don't know you should
see the movie I would let Kendall from
Big Time Rush spit in my mouth I saw a
South Park episode on that we need to uh
preface this video with if you are under
the age of 21 please 18 18. there's no
alcohol involved 18 year olds are still
oh dude we have kids yeah okay Society
Society has already ruined a song we
just ruined so many you guys yeah
anyways must be thank you for that that
was well I did laugh it really kind of
made me feel in ways that I don't even
know how to feel yes honestly I'm
honored I'll spit in your mouth anytime
problem
well if that didn't sell it enough for
you make sure you come see us on tour
for they can't get enough tour you're
not going to want to miss this
especially after all this after all that
keep on sinning can you tweet your
little heart attack Drip Drop
[Music]